hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
analytical quality control for the
pharmaceutical industry
i am tracy aston martin of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
sartorius to learn more about sartorius
visit them online at sartorius.com
let's get started i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as
many questions as you want at any time
you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
now present today's speaker joy mcilroy
joy is the owner and consultant of
mcilroy training and consultancy
llc for a complete biography on our
speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
joy you may now begin your presentation
thank you tracy thank you for that
introduction
and thank you all for attending our
presentation today
we'll go ahead and we'll get started
we'll
talking about analytical quality control
we want to understand that analytical
quality control
is referring to the process of detecting
any types of analytical errors that we
have
or that we may encounter within our
laboratories
we want to ensure that
there is reliability and all and
accuracy
of our test results because we want to
be sure
that we are manufacturing and providing
the best
possible product to our customers
we want to be sure that we do not
have any types of unreliable performing
instruments unreliable performance
can result in of course us releasing
adulterated product and of course this
can
be can be fatal to our
potentially fatal to patients that are
receiving
the product so it is great
important that we ensure that all of our
results
are provided um that are that we
provide are very are absolute accurate
and that they are reliable so this is
why
we are interested in quality
analytical quality control and not just
you know manufacturing quality control
so how do we establish analytical
quality
control we established this through
having written standard operating
procedures
as well we want to have sops
for our analytical equipment we also
want to have
written methods uh our test methods for
equipment
for our procedures that we carry out on
these instruments so
sops our standard operating procedures
are basically written instructions they
are going to document a routine or a
repetitive
activity that we follow within our
organizations we have sops in
manufacturing
for operating equipment and for
performing different types of processes
that is the same for our laboratories
we want to have sops for operating our
analytical instruments
and for performing maintenance and
calibrations on these instruments
uh we also want to have them for uh and
written test methods to follow
the reason that we provide this
documentation is to have that control
everyone is trained on these documents
everyone signs
off that they have been trained some of
uh
organizations will have us to take a
little quiz after we've read
and trained on the sop to make sure that
we understand it
um and then everyone follows this sop to
exactly as it is written
sops address requirements that
are there for us to perform jobs and
also perform them safely to operate our
instruments safely and correctly
we have to understand that the sops
will fail obviously if they're not
followed
so we want to make sure also as part of
this control
that we are reviewing sops on a regular
basis
so that we can add any new instructions
take away something that is not needed
making sure they're always accurate and
also
we need to make sure that management
is enforcing the um
these as the following of these sops
we need to train our employees our
analysts as they come
in the importance of following sops
um we'll talk a little bit and
you know just for everybody's um
information and education on the purpose
of sops we said that they detail
regularly occurring work or processes
uh in our case where we're talking about
laboratory control
uh analytical instrument control we're
talking about the regular
reoccurring testing the regular
calibrations and maintenance and
operation of this equipment
saps are also there because they
document activities that are to
be performed again with maintenance
to maintain consistency with everything
that we do
uh maintain consistency through the
calibration process
through the um the
testing process through the operation
through the preventive maintenance
they describe our types of analytical
processes
they also sops are there for validation
and qualification processes as well
we'll have
sops for qualifying our equipment
um we'll have processes for again
maintaining
and calibrating it what
sops do is they do maintain the quality
control
and they maintain quality assurance
in order to control to ensure compliance
with government regulations gops glps
those regulations that we are following
so we have sops
every sop is not going to be exactly
uh like you know every company is going
to have their different
sops depending upon their own processes
depending upon their specific industry
um depending upon their specific
manufacturing or what type of
pharmaceutical drug
that they're manufacturing so saps are
going to be
industry and um organization or
manufacturing
facility specifics
now real quickly have a look at the
components of the sops
sap should always have a purpose they
should identify a process
or a procedure you should always state a
scope of what this sop is going to cover
typically we do include the
responsibilities
and an accountability section where
we're saying you know
it is the responsibility of uh
lab analysts and technicians to
uh follow this sop some simple
statements like that and then we give
accountability for
it is management's responsibility uh to
ensure
the sops are followed so simple
statements like that then you have your
procedure section where you're
actually uh describing the process
step by step typically we'll have a
safety section if there's any safety
um concerns with the equipment do we
need to wear goggles
gloves you know things like that does it
uh whatever
the safety concerns are we'll list those
in there and then
some saps will have a training section
um
to discuss who should be trained on
the sop now that is not always necessary
uh if you have listed the
responsibilities section
whose responsibilities it is to uh
follow
the sop but the main components would be
your purpose
your process your procedure
identification your scope your
responsibility so sometimes there's
possibilities accountabilities are
combined
and then of course your procedure and
your safety section
um really quick we want to talk about
exactly what do sops need we already
said that they need to detail regularly
occurring
reoccurring work processes uh that are
are conducted within your organization
that are being followed every day so
this is it for your and your everyday
uh testing um procedures your
you know you have also your methods that
should be written down and documented
uh so we're documenting the way
activities are performed
because we what sops have to do is
facilitate consistent conformance to
technical equality system requirements
also they are going to support data
quality
okay and of course our data quality is
important we have to have
quality results in order to release this
product
saps may also describe
fundamental or pragmatic or technical
actions
again analytical processes they also
again will give procedures and processes
for
calibrating and maintaining your
equipment uh and
using equipment and also cleaning we
want to have sops
for cleaning the equipment and how we um
if there is anything uh in our
laboratories any types of instruments
that we need to break down and clean and
we want to have sops
we also want to have sops for storing um
different types of equipment uh even
down to
you know forceps and um different little
you know scissors and things that we
might use and for cleaning those as well
so what we have to understand with our
sop that we have to make sure
that we have in our saps or step-by-step
instructions um referring to
daily work that is completed and we want
this we have these in place so that this
work is performed the same
every single time it is reliable and it
is consistent
and as long as we have reliable and
consistent
um work and we're following procedures
we're doing things the same way every
day
then we're going to have control over
our processes
the next thing that we need to talk
about is
our analytical instrument qualification
this is another step in controlling
our information um one thing
also as far as our sops i'd like to
mention
we need to have sops for weighing for
pipetting
anything that we're doing in our
laboratory
we want to have specific written
instructions for doing these things
um the next would be our analytical
instrument qualification
now we have analytical
instruments qualified just as we qualify
our um our manufacturing equipment
because we have to show
that the instrument is performing
suitably
for its intended use um
when we have qualified our instruments
and we have this documented
evidence that the instrument is
performing suitably for its intended use
then it contributes obviously to the
confidence and the validity of
the generated data so we have to show
that this instrument is going to do
what it says it's going to do what the
manufacturer says
it's going to do and it's also going to
meet our purposes
in the laboratory
so there are also requirements uh
for our not only our manufacturing
equipment but our analytical instruments
to be qualified
um and for our systems
to be validated um the fda has
requirements the european union has
requirements
and we can also see these requirements
in the pics
um if you depending upon which
requirements if you follow
canadian british requirements what
whichever of those requirements that
you're following they all
are going to have requirements in there
for qualifying
your analytical instrument
um there's requirements under the good
laboratory practices
as well the glp for qualifying your
instruments um
you want to be sure that the data that
you're generating
for uh new drug applications is accurate
um and we do this again by qualifying
and showing that our instruments
are doing everything they are supposed
to do
and they're doing it on a consistent
reliable manner
uh the gmps of course have uh
regulations
the clinical practices have regulations
there's also one regulations in
21 cfr part 11 which is your electronic
records and signatures
part of the code of federal regulations
uh we any of our software systems our
computer systems that are operating
these instruments then we also have to
have
those validated we have to consider
computer system validation
and programs and making sure that those
are reliable every menu
and producing consistent information as
well
uh iso 17025 has
regulations for qualifying instruments
and i also mentioned the pics um
in these regulations in for instance the
gmps you'll see
statements that instruments should be
suitable for their intended use
and instruments should be calibrated and
maintained
so those you can have a look at these
regulations
and see these requirements
the pics the pharmaceutical inspection
convention they also have requirements
as we said for qualifying your
instruments now they come out
and if you'll have a look at the
different regulations you'll see that
some of the regulations will designate
um iqo2pq some will designate
user requirements in this slide for
instance i put up
the pics requirements
um while they may
come out and say okay this is our
specific requirements
they are all uh similar in what they are
needing
for equipment or analytical instrument
qualification
now you'll have a look the pics require
user requirements they also require a
design
qualification along with their
installation
operational and performance
qualifications of these
instruments the thing that is a little
bit different here is that they require
the factory acceptance test now a lot of
times
that is considered part of the um
the uh commissioning when the
manufacturer is bringing in the
equipment they'll do
a factory acceptance test on site to
make sure they have tested the equipment
and they'll provide you with
paperwork um and then of course
sometimes we'll do a site acceptance
test once it is
on our site and then we'll go through
the equipment qualifications with the
dqiq oqmpq
um this is just an example but have a
look at the
regulations and you'll see that
basically they are requiring the same
thing there may be a few specifics that
are different
so basically when we're talking about
instrument qualification we are
talking about a what we call a 4-q
life cycle of the design qualification
installation qualification the
operational qualification
and the performance qualifications and
these are the four basics that you're
going to find
in all of the the
regulations the requirements
so how do we set up our instruments and
how do we get them
into a suitable
if you will qualification program
the best way that i have found is by
a risk-based approach and this was uh
you can find more information on this in
the usp
1058 this is where we want to group our
instruments
according to risk
so we have low medium and high risk
instruments and we have a look at what
we have in our laboratories where we're
talking about
risks our low risk um
equipment and we can designate it as a b
and c
with c a being the lowest and c being
the highest risk
um we would have a look at what we have
in our
laboratories and any of our instruments
that do not require have any measurement
capabilities they're very
simple instruments they
do not have any calibration requirements
things that are going to be simple would
be your magnetic stirrers
your shakers sonic bass
vortex mixers these
are your very simple instruments they're
not requiring calibration and they're
not
uh having any types of measurement
capabilities such as thermometers or
things like that
um for your qualification
you would have your specifications that
are simply defined
by the manufacturer and you want to
verify
and show through documented evidence
that
these requirements have been verified
and that they these instruments are
meeting
the manufacturer's uh specifications
that you have observed that it and
seeing the operation and it's a very
simple
document um for your
for your uh qualification uh there would
not be
um well for a vortex mixer
something that you're going to have to
or a bath um
things that you're going to have to sit
on the counter and
um hook up to an electrical outlet and
things like that you would have a very
basic
installation qualification your
operational qualification would just be
simply defining and saying yes it meets
these particular specifications
uh set forth by the manufacturer
and you would just document that you
have observed it
and seen it perform and again
these are very simple and then of course
in your documentation you would show
that it does not have any maintenance
excuse me any calibration um
requirements any types of measurement
requirements these are very very very
basic
simple instruments the next category
would be your medium risk
instruments um and these are going to be
instruments
they do have measurement capabilities um
they do have uh controlled physical
parameters so
um they would be things that such as uh
instruments for
thermometers for taking temperature
pressure gauges
flow meters things like that um
for these again the um the qualification
approach um they may some of these such
as balances
uh ph meters different types of
thermometers
um like microscopes they may have
their own usp general chapters and you
can have a look at that
you would want to have user requirements
however
the user requirements are going to be
the same as the manufacturer's
specifications of functionality
and of course operational limits so
these are fairly simple as well
these will perhaps require calibration
so you're going to want to include a
calibration section in your protocols
and then you're going to simply have
your iqs and your oqs with your sops as
hell
as your editor because you're always
verifying sop's operational sops and
qualifications
um so you're going to show that they
conform to the requirements by your sops
and they will have calibration
requirements
and then you will have an installation
qualification for these instruments
uh your balances you're going to have to
show that they are installed in the
correct environment
they have um correct voltage if there's
a
any type of computer system operating
those or even
um you know any type of controller
you're going to need to show
that and then you're going to need to
show that they do need a manufactured
specifications in your operational
qualification
now for your medium risk and your low
risk
you may not have an apq which is a
performance qualification
and that's fine because these are your
low risk instruments
um in your medium risk instruments if
there is a specific
weight ranges that you're weighing for
your scales and ph
ranges that you're always measuring um
you can perform a pq
on those because your pq is going to
show
that these instruments meet your
specific
everyday requirements for use not just
that they meet the manufacturer's
requirements for use so some of these
may or may not depending upon
the type of instrument that they are
your next would be your high risk
instruments
and these are going to be your more
complex instruments
that do have operational um computer
systems
and these instruments are going to
require your full
qualification process they will need
user requirements for functionality
they will obviously have operational
requirements that need to be verified
for the manufacturer and then of course
they're going to have
performance limits and these are going
to be specific for your
analytical application um they're going
to definitely have specific
um performance and function tests
they're going to be
needing to be tested per the application
and their everyday use
um so these are going to be things such
as your hplcs
uh particle analyzers
uh your refrigerators your freezers your
incubators
even your autoclaves and your stability
chambers so these are you're going to
your very complex
equipment you will want to start out
with a dq
then which is your design qualification
and we'll discuss that in just a moment
uh you will have an iq an oq and a pq
for each one
of these your most complex instruments
what you do when you group these and you
base your instruments on
a risk then you gain advantage because
you have a better
faster simpler cheaper qualification
process you're using uniform and
consistent protocols this allows you to
have basic
templates for your simple instruments
basic templates
qualification protocol templates for
your
low medium and high risk instruments and
then you're able to fill in the
information
you're creating harmonization um so
this is uh to me
it's if you don't have to create the
wheel every time you're not
writing a new protocol from scratch
every time it allows
um you can get these protocols written
get them executed and get them
reviewed by quality assurance and
approved in a more timely manner
and it makes it a lot easier and you
have all of your instruments
grouped so that you know the
qualifications and the um
the um what each instrument the
how complicated each instrument is and
what's going to be involved
you have a one straight
protocol for all of your various types
of manufacturers and then you of course
are just filling in
information such as model numbers
manufacturers
names by doing this on a risk
base you are going to improve your
compliance and your productivity
obviously you're going to simplify your
testing because you do
have standard tests and procedures that
you're going to know
is going to be needed for each different
type of instrument
um it gives you of course faster
turnaround times for getting this
information reviewed and of course it
makes your paperwork
uniform and it allows for quality
assurance
to review them on a faster basis as well
so what the risk-based approach does is
it simplifies
grouping of course because you're
grouping from lowest to highest it
also can reduce the cost and it also is
going to improve your efficiency
because it does allow you to maximize
the use of vendor documents
and employees protocol harmonization now
i do have to
caution against vendor documents
you can use vendor documents for these
and for your simple ones it's very
it's fine to do this when you use a
vendor document however
i would if you use a vendor document
please have your quality assurance
department
review it and approve it just like you
would with your protocols you're going
to write your protocols
route them for review and approval for
management and quality assurance
so you want to do the same thing with
these have a cover page
and have them have approval page
so that you know that management and
quality assurance has reviewed them for
thoroughness accuracy and that they are
including everything that's needed
because sometimes vendor protocols
do not include everything that is
necessary
the vendor doesn't have a way of knowing
exactly what is needed
for your facility so just be sure that
you do have those reviews
a lot of time we did say that user
requirements are required
and particularly for your complex
instruments
um we refer to user requirements as
urs's um one thing we want to understand
about user requirements
is they have to be comprehensive um
we want to be sure that they are also
testable
all of your user requirements have to be
testable
um so you want to look at each and every
requirement
for that piece of that analytical
instrument
as it relates to product safety identity
um also strength security and quality
so you want to have quality assurance
has to have again a significant role in
reviewing and approving your user
requirements just as they do
uh your iq ogs and pqs
um so
your user requirements are very
important um
the one thing i think that i do see a
lot of
is remembering that user requirements
have to be comprehensive
and they have to be testable and they
have to be reviewed
by your quality assurance group as well
for a dq your design qualification
the fda is now moving towards requiring
this and this has not always
been a requirement unless you had a
specific piece of equipment or
analytical instrument designed
for your in your specific use
um now the fda
and other regulatory bodies are
requiring
a design qualification so
what the design qualification is
um it is used at the design phase
obviously
we want to show that this instrument has
been developed from the vmp from the
user requirements
uh from other health and safety
guidelines
we want to be sure it has been reviewed
and documented by competent people
because we're ensuring the design of the
equipment
that it is built or it hasn't built or
if it is built
that it will satisfy all of the detailed
specified requirements that it's going
to function
as it is designed to function as it is
required to function so that's what
we're doing
with a design qualification um we are
showing
that this instrument was built
or it has been built in order to
function
as it is as as needed so it was
specifically designed to do
these particular processes for your
installation qualification
um your installation qualification is
going to be the process
of checking the installation
you want to show documented evidence
that
the instrument has the correct component
that it needs to operate properly
that it has been installed properly in
the
proper environment the
installation qualification is to ensure
that all
aspects of the facility and or your
equipment
are installed correctly and that they
comply with
the original design
you want to be sure that you're
documenting within your
installation qualifications that your
software that's operating the equipment
is updated it is the correct software
it's in the correct environment
there is uh has enough room in that
environment to operate properly
um that there are the uh
proper sops
for this equipment that this equipment
or this analytical instrument
is um doing is is installed correctly
um and that it will function in this
environment the noise level
uh different types of text wanting to
make sure that you have
calibration procedures in place for this
that
anything on that instrument that needs
to be calibrated
is going to be calibrated at regular
intervals
so that is what your installation
qualification is documenting
your operational qualification is
documenting
um what the manufacturer
says this instrument will do so it's
testing to ensure that the individual or
combined systems
will function to meet performance
criteria
as specified by the manufacturer
you want to ensure that it does also
comply with original design that it is
going to do exactly what the
manufacturer
says that it will do you want to check
the instrument's
functions um to ensure that they conform
to the specifications now these are not
conforming to
uh your specific specifications for the
test that you're running
uh it's conforming to what the
manufacturer says
um so for instance if you have
um a ph meter and i'll give you a very
uh simple simple um illustration
that the manufacturer says you know it
will detect ph
from you know one to ten
um you're checking to make sure that it
does that
um if you have uh an autoclave or a
refrigerator and if the manufacturer
says
refrigerator for instance the
manufacturer
says you know it will the temperature
range is i don't know
say 2 to 10 degrees
c then you check your testing should
show that it
is running within those specified
temperatures um so
what you're doing with your your oq is
you're showing that it will meet
manufacturer specifications
your iq you're showing that it's
installed correctly
your oq you're showing that it will meet
manufacturer specifications
uh you want to be sure that you do have
an
iq performed on each piece of
analytical equipment before you move on
to your oq your oq
needs to be performed for each different
use of your equipment
each or system if even if you have the
same model
and type because you want to document
suitability for the use okay so if you
have
um instruments that are being used
they're the same instruments and they're
being used for different processes or
different types of testing
you would need to perform an oq for each
one of those types of testing
you do not it is not a requirement to
perform
an oq for the same model or the same
type of equipment that is for the same
use but it is
if they are going to be for different
uses
but you do have to have your iq
performed
for before you can begin your oq
the next way part of our qualification
is your performance qualification
your performance qualification is
documented evidence
that your instrument is consistently
performing according to
specifications that are appropriate
which routine use
so you're going to have particular test
methods that you're going to routinely
run
on this analytical instrument and what
you're showing in your performance
qualification
is that okay in your oq it means
specific manufacturers
settings and specifications in your pq
it's meeting its everyday
routine uh specifications uh and meeting
those particular
parameters so um
in your pq your performance
excuse me your testing is going to be a
little bit higher
uh level testing than your oq because it
is for your particular
function for your facility for that
everyday use of that instrument
another thing another way once we
have our standard operating procedures
in place we have
documented evidence of our user
requirements and our qualification
processes
all of this remember is we are
qualifying
and documenting this qualification we're
providing user requirements in order to
show
controls um to show that we have
tested these instruments and they're
going to perform consistently
reliably uh and they're going to do the
same meeting the same parameters every
time
and this is how you establish control um
the last thing that you're going to need
to do for control
is to re-qualify your instruments you do
not want to qualify them one time
and say that this is all i'm ever going
to need to do
because you want to have continuous
confidence
in your analytical results for the
entire life of that instrument
so you're going to need to put your
instruments set up your instruments in a
re-qualification
program um your simple instruments
those types are a lot of times you're
just gonna have that generate that
protocol as they come
in if they're instruments that you are
using over and over for long periods of
time
then you can show uh go back through
that qualification and verify that it's
continuously working and meeting those
qualifications
and your medium risks the same way for
your higher your critical uh your most
complex
instruments like your incubators
refrigerators your hplcs
um gcs different things like that
you are going to set these instruments
up on an
annual qualification basis where you're
basically going back
through the operational qualification
and retesting and saying yes it's still
meaning this test case is still meaning
this
also if you've updated sops if you
change something about the operation
then you need to um show that and then
it's meeting
the requirements it's operational
requirements
uh and also its performance requirements
and you need to do this annually
if the instruments are not critical you
can re-qualify them
on an every three to five year basis i
would not go
myself over three years but it is
acceptable to
have them on a three to five year
requalification
basis what you're doing when you're
re-qualifying is of course you're
retaining confidence
um that the instrument is continuously
working and also
you're showing inspectors uh from
whatever regulatory body
that the instrument has maintained its
qualified state uh you do not perform
an iq because obviously it is
installed correctly um
again i jumped ahead of myself a little
bit but the re-qualifications every two
to three years
and it can go out as far as five years
for your instruments that are not
critical
and anything that is critical should be
done on an annual basis
the last way of maintaining control is
going to be
through quality auditing you want to set
up
and again everything that we do in our
labs
everything needs to have an sop so you
need to have a
standard operating procedure for
carrying out quality audits
you need to have a standard operating
procedure for carrying out quality
equipment qualifications and writing
protocols
as well as how your equipment operates
and cleaning your equipment and
storing your equipment um and the
everyday functions of your laboratory
because when you have it written down
and you have it documented and everyone
is following it
then everyone is doing the same thing on
a consistent reliable basis
and they're doing it the same and you're
getting the very same manufactured
product
the same test results every single time
um
if there is anything that is not testing
the testing comes back
failing then you're obviously going to
be able to detect it
and reject the product and you're going
to be assured that you're releasing
um quality product all the time so the
last thing would be your quality audits
and quality auditing is basically the
process of systematic examination
of a particular quality system whether
it is internal or external
and it can be done by an internal audit
team or an external audit team
you want to have your procedures audited
on a regular basis have a lot of times
we do have the qa quality assurance
department will come in
they'll audit and look at the
performance the analysts and what
they're doing
i have the equipment operation and look
at the
overall operation of the laboratory
they'll have a checklist that they go by
and they'll say yes everything is
performing or they may make some
citations or
some observations if we say they're not
citations
by a regulatory body um and they'll
you know say okay i observed this and
this person wasn't following the sop
or the gowning wasn't appropriate for
the laboratory we do also need to have
appropriate gowning with lab coats and
appropriate ppe is necessary for
operating the equipment
and all of that would be an sop so when
we're auditing
we're looking at all of this and we're
having checklists and making sure that
everything is in compliance
that way when we have an inspector to
come in we're not going to get
cited and they're going to ask
also to see our internal audits and see
what we have
um have done the audit to help determine
if the organization is of course
compliant with your quality system
processes
again it is procedural and results-based
assessment they may also look at your
test records we want to be sure that we
have uniform test records
we want to be sure that we have sops
that are in a documentation system
so all of this is a way to make sure
that your analytical instruments are in
a state of
control and that you're performing on
performing correctly the same consistent
spaces every single day um
thank you we will now open for any
questions
that you may have
thank you joy for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
we already have some great questions
coming in so while i give joy
a few moments to review the questions
that have already come in
i want to remind our audience how to
submit questions
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as
we have time for okay joy which question
would you like me to start with
um just give me one second i am
okay i see them now um we can start with
um
number two number two
are user requirements necessary for
simple
instruments such as pipette
yes
use the requirements for your simple
instruments
are going to be basically what the um
the manufacturer says that they will do
so um
let me say that
when you write user requirements it's
not necessary
for your simple instruments uh because
basically your user requirements are
going to be
um the functionality of that instrument
for your simple instruments now when you
move into
your medium risk and your
complex instruments yes you will need to
have user requirements
for your simple instruments if you would
like to write
a section of user requirements is going
to be the basic
um functionality and specifications
as set forth by the manufacturer
okay thank you joy what other what's the
next question
um let's see
let's um let's see number 17
number 17 this question is
is an interesting question how many
times
should equipment be calibrated before
performance
well that's going to depend on the type
of equipment that it is
for instance and it's also going to
depend upon the manufacturing
requirements um
for example if it's a simple uh ph meter
then you may need to calibrate it before
each use
um if it is a
scale obviously we calibrate those
before each use
if you're talking about your performance
qualification you're going to show
your your calibration uh within your
operational
qualification but for your everyday use
it's going to depend on what type of
equipment
and how often your manufacturer requires
that it
needs to be calibrated like i said some
things like scales
balances ph meters may require
a once a day calibration before the
initial use of the day
and others may not um so i would refer
to the um the manufacturer's manual
for the calibration and you can also put
that in your sop
for the operation of the particular
instrument
alrighty
um let's i see question number one
number one okay how often should
sops be reviewed for accuracy
that's a good question too thank you uh
so much
um sops should be reviewed for accuracy
on at least a bi-annual basis
i have seen some companies that will
review them
annually and some companies will review
them
every three to five years first of all
you need to for your price
for your process validations
we are constantly looking at our
processes and
updating sops as necessary um
for your analytical applications um
i would review these sops i do not like
to go
over two years without reviewing the sop
for accuracy
remember that anytime you change an sop
or a function on a piece of equipment or
you change the use then obviously you're
going to have to have that
instrument requalified but your sops
need to be reviewed for actually in my
opinion
at least on a bi-annual basis
okay
let me see i'm just looking at the
questions um
okay i key number 15 that that looks
like this number two question
15 okay here we go
uh is it mandatory for academic
research institutions working on funded
projects from
industry needs to have sops and follow
them
um if you are being funded from a you
know a regulated industry
yes um i would
yes you need to have sops because that
industry is going
to be ultimately responsible for
your work i think that it is a
good idea to have sops regardless
because what sops do again establish
everyday working processes that are
going to be performed
we understand that sometimes when you're
doing research or doing a project for a
funded industry
a funded project from an industry that
you're not going to maybe have
consistencies
based on the different type of research
but you can have sops for different for
basic operation of your equipment
basic functions in your laboratory so um
it and then ultimately if the industry
is funding
then they're going to be ultimately
responsible so yes you should have sop
okay okay great well we have time
for one more question today i want to
remind our audience that those
yep i want to remind our audience that
uh those questions we were unable to
answer
and those that come in during the
on-demand period will be
answered by joy via the email address
you provided at the time
of registration so our final question
joy
um give me i'm sorry give me one second
because i i see a
quite a few and i'm i don't want to
leave anyone out but we will get them
answered
um
okay there's how about number number 28
number 28
okay quality audits may be internal
or external what about requalification
should it be done only by the original
quality certifier
now by the original quality certifier
i'm assuming you're talking about your
original equipment manufacturer
re-qualifications
can be done by either one
the original equipment manufacturer
or by your own
validation department within your
facility
if you're if you have
an outside the equipment manufacturer
coming in to qualify this instrument
and they are using their documents again
have your quality assurance and your
management review those documents
for accuracy and making sure that they
have
what is needed in those documents per
your facility
um typically i like to see
companies perform their own
requalifications
like to see them perform their own
qualifications with their own documents
because
you know what is needed for your piece
of equipment
and you don't have to go through
sometimes a bunch of requirements that
are not necessary
so it is my opinion that you should
qualify
your instruments initially you may use
sender documents you may have the vendor
come in
sometimes you do buy that service um and
that is perfectly fine
to have the original
equipment manufacturer to come in and
qualify the instrument and to come back
and forth and perform
the re-qualifications on that instrument
as long as they're doing it
according to your standards and meeting
your quality parameters and that
paperwork
those protocols are have all of the
requirements
that are necessary for you um otherwise
then you should re-qualify your own
instrument
on your own re-qualification schedule
um because you as the manufacturer
you as the uh manufacturing facility
know your specific testing you know your
specific requirements
for that instrument but either way is
sufficient i just want you to make sure
that you
are reviewing what the um
original equipment manufacturer is doing
with the qualification process if you
choose to use them
oh and one more thing i'm sorry all of
your documents should be
and also your vendor document should be
signed off
approved by management equality
assurance
okay well thank you again joy do you
have any final comments for our audience
today
yes and thank you um i just want to say
i appreciate your attendance
um when you the one thing i wanted to
say is through this
the purpose of this types
all these types of documentation from
your sops
to your equipment qualification
protocols
to performing your quality audits um
obviously you're
documenting that your equipment
your testing is in a state of control
and that you're producing
quality uh data and then
thereby releasing quality product it is
really all about documentation uh be
sure
that you are documenting uh everything
that you're doing
and um that your quality assurance
department
and your policy control um quality
assurance excuse me is
involved and they're signing off and
reviewing each of these documents
because your control is coming from your
documentation
a lot of times the fda if they don't see
it
and it's not written down it didn't
happen and that is the only way as
inspectors
that we can see that you are doing what
you're supposed to be doing
and you're doing it in a consistent
reliable controlled manner
so again i just thank you for your
attendance today
thank you very much thank you again
joy mcilroy for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor sartorius for
underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye